the temple of angkor wat
is one of hundreds of temples that make
up the ancor
world heritage site
angkor was once the largest city on
earth
then seemingly overnight this ancient
metropolis of nearly a million souls
vanished now
experts are using new technology to
solve this great mystery
and restore the treasures of a lost
empire
damian evans is one of a new breed
they call themselves aerial
archaeologists
he's on a mission to map the ruins of
the lost
civilization below
what we do is we look at the landscape
as a whole
if you're on the ground you really can't
see what's what
you really have to get up in the air and
get an overview a broader perspective on
the landscape
new technologies are allowing damien to
trace urban boundaries and landmarks
like
never before
lasers mounted on the helicopter can cut
through the jungle to detect
topographical details
hidden beneath
for the first time damien is able to map
the full reach
of this ancient mega city
the maps show the area of angkor was the
size of
modern day los angeles that angkor was
the largest
settlement complex that had ever been
built in all of human history
before the industrial revolution
ancient ancor was the capital city of
the mighty khmer
empire for six centuries
this military superpower conquered and
controlled a vast
kingdom in southeast asia
then just as europe was entering the
renaissance
this thriving 3 000 square kilometer
city
was swallowed up by the jungle
damian is searching for patterns below
that may indicate
how this city functioned and why it
suddenly collapsed
the problem here is that you can be
standing right in the middle of a city
a thousand-year-old city and not even
know that you're right on top of it
once you get up in the air you're able
to map these things you can see the
spatial patterning the traces of these
things in the landscape his teammate
scott hawkin coordinates from the ground
scott's expertise is in decoding the
ruins
of ancient cities stone structures
were built for the gods
so temples are nearly all that remain
standing
but new laser technology can detect the
traces of structures that disappeared
hundreds of years ago we found hundreds
and hundreds of additional temples
we found the remains of canals even a
small road
from a thousand years ago even if it's
completely overgrown
you can still see the trace of that road
[Music]
why this thriving capital disappeared is
a total mystery
the inhabitants of angkor left no
written records
that indicate an invasion plague or
other catastrophic event
so what did go wrong here
while damian and scott look for answers
other teams in the park are in a more
present day struggle
they're out to save the fragile temples
left behind
glenn bornazian is a lead architect for
the world monuments fund
if we can find any glenn is directing a
massive effort to prevent one of the
park's oldest temples
from literally crumbling apart
[Music]
the number one enemy of this place is
water when water gets behind
it is an exponential process so it was
basically
a systematic collapse of the site
the upper stone shrine we have the same
problem everywhere
we can see that the the facade stone has
all collapsed
because of the erosion over time and the
amount of water that came in
and that dirt gets wet and puts pressure
on this facade wall
it's caused the collapse
what do you think the next steps are to
try to fix it
we uh start with the stabilize
with the new lateral eye block at the
bed just like the ancestor did
before right
the temples then and now are built by
stacking a core of laterite
then encasing it in intricately carved
sandstone these stones are so
tightly laid that you can see behind me
you can't stick a piece of paper in
between them
today if you ask somebody to do this
wall almost impossible
the first step of the restoration is
removing the ancient sandstone
blocks so the team can install
a new ladderite foundation
it's a huge undertaking there are stone
coming down
[Music]
and there's stone going up
this is a very busy place
to the workers that built this temple in
900 a.d
glenn's modern tools would have seemed
like magic
the crane can do in weeks what would
have taken
thousands of workers decades to build
using a single crane glenn's crew can
move up to 15
one-ton blocks of laterite every day
good let's keep bringing it down and
good
now the site is ready for the original
sandstone blocks
to be put back in place
the crown jewel of the whole site is the
800 year old
angkor wat
the temple complex is a literal
depiction of hindu cosmology
carved in stone it took some 300
000 workers about 40 years to build
this enormous temple
[Music]
certified guide potai kin believes
angkor wat and other temples
are entering a new age of peril
the age of mega tourism
[Music]
we have buses loaded with tourists
coming in each day from three thousand
to
four thousand five thousand a day coming
into the park
you walk along the gallery of the bar
relief you see people just
touching to that bar relief and
sometimes
a whole tour group which is putting
their hands in there
when i see the temple that's being
damaged i
just feel sad
[Music]
ankle and ankle what is part of the soul
of
cambodia it's buried in our heart
as the symbol of our people
the surface of this monument it's part
of the history
[Music]
we could erase the history
[Music]
the best way to discover why angkor
vanished
is to understand how it thrived in the
first place
damian and scott are looking for
structures that reveal how a small
jungle village grew into a sprawling
urban superpower damien i can see you i
can see the chopper
you're just nearly there scott's on the
hunt for specific
details that will expose the true story
behind these ruins i'm just walking
along the face of the wall now
[Music]
and it's uh made of these massive
lateral blocks
the blocks are like over a metre length
uh very
nicely carved ladder right and butter
together very precisely
this is a precision engineered structure
scott has just come across a major find
what's going on down there i'm walking
down what looks like to be this
monumental stair
between these great ladderite blocks
there's another
architectural feature
of the other side
these two massive parallel walls look
like they could have been used for
some kind of channel whether it was used
to stop water going in or
going out that's that's hard to say
these ruins appear to be part of an
ancient canal
i think the interpretation is probably
spot on actually i can't see it being
anything else
other than a water outlet right there
they've now found a key piece to the
puzzle
new aerial imagery has revealed an
ingenious network of canals and
reservoirs
throughout the city obviously the
reservoir behind me is easy to see
for the most part though we can't see
water in them today
but we can look at traces and features
of the landscape
that tell us that we have this huge
water management system here
even the river in the modern town is
actually an
ancient canal still flowing today as it
did a thousand years ago
the centerpiece of the system is an
eight kilometer long
two kilometer wide reservoir just
outside the city
this reservoir alone would have taken
six thousand
workers more than six years to dig out
by hand
the team wants to know why the ancient
khmer
went to such lengths to divert water on
such a massive scale
a long time there was this idea that
there were purely
religious structures just there for the
gods
and spiritual reflection
but looking at these stone features that
are inserted
in the walls of the reservoir you can
understand that these are
functional engineered features and they
would have
been able to handle vast quantities of
water
understanding how this system function
will help
damian and scott reconstruct the rise of
the khmer
empire and perhaps uncover
the reasons for its downfall
[Music]
when the khmer empire collapsed the
temples of angkor were lost to the world
for over 400 years
by the time french explorers founded in
1860
the temple had nearly been devoured by
the jungle
a special unit of the forestry team is
gearing up to defend angkor wat
from an unexpected threat
pigeon guano has sprouted seedlings high
above
on top of the temple towers
[Music]
if the tree is allowed to grow the root
will go deeper and deeper into the
stones
it will destroy the whole temple
the only way to remove these invaders
is to climb
[Music]
the climbers are nearly 65 meters above
the ground
now the team can get to work
they remove every plant they see
and pour a poison to keep the roots from
sprouting again
weeding duty at angkor is no walk in the
park
it's scary at the top because it is so
high but the view is beautiful
[Music]
this is our little contribution
we are very proud to be able to protect
our heritage
[Music]
meanwhile damian and scott are trying to
uncover the secret
of the khmer empire's success
[Music]
a new clue lies in the ruins of an
ancient canal
[Music]
i can see some um circular holes and
other grooves which could have been
these fittings for wooden structures
it looks like there's some other
structure integrated within the into the
wall here
[Music]
the need to change the flow at different
times of year
points to only one thing
the climate
cambodia has only two seasons wet
and dry
the key problem for early civilizations
in this area is you have too much water
for half the year and not enough water
for the other half of the year
so the secret of success of
civilizations in this area
is their ability to develop
technological solutions to that
fundamental problem
of water supply the ancient khmer
designed a system that could store
excess rain in the wet season and then
disperse it
in the dry season the key was digging
enormous reservoirs from the helicopter
it gives us an opportunity to see the
reservoir
and we can see how that outlet is
plugged into a system of distribution
when the spillway was opened tremendous
water pressure from the reservoir
forced water down a network of canals
and into the rice fields below
this is the reason why the anchor
civilization was extremely successful
because their engineering achievements
in terms of water management were
unparalleled pretty much anywhere else
in the world
[Music]
this engineering feat would be massive
even today
what this hydraulic superstructure did
was
provide stability for the city of ancor
so if the rains failed there was this
backup system
so the farmers could still continue to
grow their rice
some 48 000 square kilometers of fertile
rice paddies
supported a huge urban population
and turned ancient anchor into a
dominant
empire now the question is
why and how did it all fall apart
today all that remains are these ruins
of a lost age
angkor was founded in the 9th century as
a representation
of hindu cosmology
like the ancient mayans across the globe
the khmer calendar was based on the
cycles of the heavens
[Music]
now twice a year taurus can witness
a celestial event that the khmer kings
used
to demonstrate their divine right
[Music]
it's when the sunlight coming straight
over our head
and the sun comes straight from the top
of the towers
and it brings this beam of light down
the alignment of the capstone focuses an
intense beam
into the ceremonial chamber
you see this light falling from that
hole on the top the towers
and then it falls right straight on the
top of the pedestal
when it happened twice a year and that's
what the
my king believed that this is the way
that they could reach to the god to
reach to the heaven
the king could communicate with the god
the
khmer king believed that they are deva
raja
the deva raja means the god king
the kings used their divine power to
command
thousands of servants to build the
temples and reservoirs
that turned angkor into an ancient
mega city
the khmer empire's transition to
buddhism in the 13th century
was a fundamental shift
for one the kings were no longer
venerated as gods
building hindu temples came to a halt
and new evidence suggests they may have
stopped maintenance work on their
complex water system
as well we know that they have this very
delicate water management system
and we know that towards the end of the
encore period the water management
system collapsed
the big issue for us has always been why
archaeologists have discovered a
stunning clue
hidden in the jungle below some
colleagues of mine
have managed to go up into the highlands
cut down one of these
ancient trees and look at the tree rings
inside that tree
what they can do is reconstruct rainfall
on an annual basis
going back hundreds and hundreds of
years right back to the ancor period
it shows us these incredible droughts
these periods of
20 or 30 years of very very low rainfall
right at the end of the ancor period for
a water system
already in disrepair this mega drought
would have been catastrophic
ironically the city was doomed
by its own ingenuity their increasing
use of technology
and this expanding water system allowed
them to move into more marginal areas of
the landscape
but this made them dependent on this
hydraulic superstructure
when the system failed during the
drought angkor could not grow enough
rice
to sustain itself and the civilization
collapsed all that remains of this
mighty
empire are ruins
the pressure on the park to protect
these monuments
is enormous but the teams of workers and
researchers never rest
in their fight to preserve the last
legacy
of the lost city of angkor
you